[Music]
the Dick Van Dyke Show the Dick Van Dyke
Show has been turned into color for the
very first time ever for a holiday
presentation and we joined dick and show
creator Carl Reiner at Carl's home they
shared some stories that you may have
never heard before the Dick Van Dyke
Show Starring Dick Van Dyke
I had this idea that comedy should be in
black and white and but the in this
process they did it looks like it was
shot in color there's nothing fake about
it I was covered I had brown hair
everybody thought I had black hair and
Mary Tyler Moore Mary got her big break
as dicks wife Reiner cast the former
model and dancer despite the age
difference between her and dick I said
she's a little younger that's the first
thing he said how nice how old was the
difference in your over 12 years what
else and and I said nobody's gonna nod
nobody ever ever even mentioned that
they worked him to fart the first time
they kissed on on the pilot that was it
I work together
I just felt romantic today I had a real
crush on her they really were attracted
to each other but they both had
relationships and they they were very
circumspect but they were really
attracted towards you
well III died I don't think it's right
for you to wear that dress when I'm not
with you we became like an improv you
could just tell us a saying that we can
we could make it up she read me very
well and I read her timing very well
that it just it was such a pleasure to
work with her running from 1961 to 66
dick played a TV comedy writer for a
show where Ryder was the egotistical
star show won 15 Emmy Awards but wasn't
a breakout hit at first you know we got
to cancel at the end of the first year
and we thought it was over and thank God
that I think it's a summer rerun people
saw know did you know the one out of
every 50 million women has the wrong
baby that's a cute trick
how does she
you use electric we use the audience and
now you put a door slams you there the
laughter now with two colorized episodes
airing Sunday night on CBS the 90 year
old legend is feeling the style it was
ever worth ever and as I said I shall be
doing it respect me there was nothing
like it nothing like
you
you